Let's see whether you can come up with an invariant check of function yourself.
As an example, we're going to use zip code.
The zip code is what you need to address a letter to a specific address.
The zip code is a number or in some countries a sequence of numbers and letters
that identifies a specific region in some country.
For our example, we're going to use American zip codes,
which in their most basic form are five digits,
and those five digits go from five zero to five nine
that is each of the five digits is between zero and nine.
So, here's a zip code class.
Again, we have a constructor, which takes the zip code
which is a string consisting out of five digits.
We set zip, internal zip attribute to the string--again, five digits.
We also have a method to retrieve the zip code again as a string
and now we need to come up with an appropriate representation checker
invariant checker that checks whether the state is okay.
We could, for instance, start with making sure that the length of the zip code is precisely five.
Now, go and complete the invariant checker such that
the content of the string is also checked
such as that each of the digits is between zero and nine -- over to you.